a sphere made of swiss
cheese a sphere with the texture of
swiss
cheese and there you have it
beautiful very appetizing swiss cheese
balls
my swiss heart had just just skipped a
beat
out of this monstrosity what's even
cooler than a sphere
made of swiss cheese is a taurus
made of denim
these images are so cool a taurus made
of denim
and the point here is that these images
aren't photoshopped or
sort of human created they are ai
generated
and they are generated by this new model
that openai uh released a blog post
about it's called
dali and it can what it can do is it can
take a piece of text such as the one
on top here the fact that i can select
is simply
the fact that they don't give you access
to the model they just give you access
of a bunch of things that they've tried
but the model can take
any piece of text and it can output a
picture that matches that text so
here you got a taurus made of toothpaste
and the quality of these images
is super astounding and what's even more
astounding
is sort of the range of capabilities
that this
model has so the model can do
various things such as so in here the
input
is an illustration of a baby daikon
radish in a tutu walking a dog
and you see an illustration of a baby
diagon radish
in a tutu walking a dog the outputs are
just adorable these are generated by the
ai
it's the same for an armchair in the
shape of an avocado
a storefront that has the word open ai
written on it
i've tried reverse image searching some
of these images and i could not
find them on the internet so it's
definitely not just a model sort of
outputting
an image it found somewhere these are
actually generated images
and the astounding thing is that it's
the same
model that outputs all of these
different images it's not one model here
trained on illustrations and one model
trained on chairs
it's a single model that can take
in a piece of text and optionally
part of an image or none of an image
and it will output the image either
it continues the image you already gave
part of or
it just generates the image by itself
so the model is called dali and this is
just a blog post for now by open ai
they say they'll follow this up with a
paper and
if the paper you know brings
substantially new things i think
i'll make a video on it but today we're
just going to look at
what this model can do how it works how
it probably works and we can take some
guesses of what we can
read in the paper once it's out in fact
openai has
brought out two new models along with
this dali model they've also
released a blog post and a paper about a
model called
clip which is more of a sort of a
classifier not exactly a classifier
it's sort of a it connects text and
images
in a different way it's not a generative
model
and we're going to look at that in a in
a different video but you can see the
clear trend right here is that open ai
is looking into connecting
text and images so they say
dali which is an this is a an i think a
an homage to
salvador dali and mixed with the
character
wall-e so they say it's a 12 billion
parameter version of gpt-3
so you know it's more like it's more
like not
gpt3 that was more than 10 times larger
but it's a 12 billion parameter version
of gpt3
trained to generate images from text
descriptions
using a data set of text image pairs
we found that it has diverse set of
capabilities including
creating anthropomorphized versions of
animals and objects
combining unrelated concepts in
plausible ways rendering text
and applying transformations to existing
images
so a lot of the things they don't tell
us here
especially the data set like how did
they get the data set
nobody knows they don't say this they
simply say it's a data set of text
image pairs and they sort of allude to
the fact
that they have large pieces of data
especially
in the clip then they they allude to the
fact that you can just
find data that connects text and images
on the internet and it's true if you if
you search
if you scrape the correct websites and
do it in sort of a smart fashion
you can find a lot of data where there's
an image and there's a piece of text
describing that image and
we have to assume that they sort of
scrape the internet for something like
this
i don't think they have a lot of human
explicitly human labeled data
for this type of thing so we'll just
assume that they have like a huge data
set and
of course they train a huge model on it
a 12 billion parameter version of gpt3
gpt
3 is the famous model the famous text
generation model
by open ai and um
you can sort of see the same things
right here so gpt 3
my hypothesis was is that it sort of
smartly
mixes the training data rather than
remember
the training data it it sort of
remembers it and then smartly
interpolates between it and i think
you can sort of see the same kind of
things
right here in that these are all
definitely pictures that you could
imagine in the real world
but they have you know they have for
example their change to open ai
in here there are surely chairs that
sort of look
like this so it just kind of mixes a
chair with an avocado in a plausible way
i'm not saying this to denigrate the
model i'm saying
that i mean this is seriously cool the
fact that it can do that
so they say like gpt3 delhi is a
transformer
language model now this is very very
interesting
the fact that it's a transformer
language model
it receives both the text and the image
as a single stream of data containing
up to 1 and 1 280
tokens it's trained using maximum
likelihood to generate
all of the tokens one after another
okay this training procedure allows
dolly not only to generate images from
scratch
but also to regenerate any rectangular
region of an existing image that extends
to the bottom right corner
in a way that is consistent with the
text prompt
and they say a little bit more here on
the right
and they also say a little bit more down
on the bottom
so i'm going to try to take a step of
explaining
how this model works with the full
knowledge that i might be wrong
once the paper comes out and for that we
have to go
back a little bit and look at the models
it draws from namely
the vq vaes so the vector quantized vae
literature
so vq va
will consider this to be sort of the
inspiration
of um or one of the necessary
ingredients
of this model so if we combine
vq vae with something like gpt
3 we get dolly
that's my that's my hypothesis for today
um why combining these two models so
gpt3 is extremely good at modeling
language right
so if i have a piece of text
let's go down here for a minute and
let's say
i have a a cat
set on the mat
a transformer will be very good at
understanding the sentence
and being able to complete it so if i
cross out this and ask a transformer
to continue the sentence it will be able
to continue the sentence
just fine if it is if it is trained well
and that's exactly how gpt
3 works now imagine that
i don't have a piece of text but i have
some sort of a
description of an image right let's say
i have
i have a box here is a box
and the box which is going to be a vq
vae
can take in a description of an image in
words but not exactly words that human
humans understand but let's say there is
an image language
sort of like a programming language okay
and
you input symbols into the
image let's say it's a bit like egyptian
hieroglyphs maybe
so here is the here is the
this this hieroglyph thing and then
there is the sun
the sun thing and then there is the the
tree
the word for tree like the hieroglyphic
and i input that here and the output
will be an image where i don't know
there the sun is shining
yes i draw a song like a child it has a
little smile
okay deal with it and there is a tree
maybe not exactly the tree from the
hieroglyphs but like some sort of
some sort of tree that fits and then
there is some human
in the scene maybe the human sits here
the human sits
at the tree you know relaxing
chilling okay so
um this now the image on the right is
consistent of pixels
right and modeling pixels with a
transformer is
very very hard because in in the case of
our model right here
it's something like 256 by 256
pixels that would mean the transformer
would have to generate 256
times 250 which is like 2 to the
2 to the 16. this is just too much for a
transformer to model
the pixels individually so there are
multiple ways around this for example
modeling
little regions right here which are not
really satisfactory
so what this model does is it sort of it
doesn't try to model the picture as such
it tries
to predict to predict these hieroglyphs
right here it tries to predict sort of a
language
that this box can understand and produce
a picture
from okay so its task is going to be
given some sort of a given some sort of
a text prefix
so a human um
[Music]
in a sunny field sunny
day or on a sunny day
chilling under a tree
so this piece of text followed
so the the model is trained to take this
piece of text
and output this sequence of hieroglyphs
okay so this sequence of hieroglyphs
outputting
from this piece of text
and that's something a transformer can
do if
you have a vocabulary right here so if
you have a fixed list of hieroglyphs
that you could use
right so in there there is the the human
is in there
[Music]
that's a worse egyptian um and then the
pyramid is in here as well some that you
need some that you don't need
so if there is a vocabulary the
transformer is going to be pretty pretty
good
at generating this thing so you need you
need two parts
the first part right here is a
transformer a
language model a gpt3 thing that can
input a sequence of text and it can
output a sequence of text which is just
in a different vocabulary namely this
picture vocabulary and then in the step
you need a box that takes in this
picture vocabulary and actually produces
an images
an image right here so as i already said
this part is taken over by
gpt gpt3
like the the custom gpt model they built
for this and this part is taken over by
something like a vq vae
the generator part of it so what is a vq
vae
a vq vae is and you will
be able to see that um
so the box that we're going to need is
this box right here from from here
up to where the image is and this thing
right here
is going to be that vocabulary so what
does a vq vae do
it takes the image here on the left you
can see that here is the encoder
it takes the image it encodes it into a
latent space
now what if what a vae would do
or what an auto encoder would do is it
would encode the image into a latent
space
and then it would decode it again into
and try to reproduce the same image
and then you assume that whatever is in
the middle right here
is a sensible representation a latent
representation of that image right if
you can train this model
you're going to get some sort of a
representation in the middle
that describes the image otherwise you
couldn't reproduce the image
and there have been many models built on
this concept
now this model right here it turns out
that the classic
auto encoder doesn't work too well
but this model works quite formidably so
what you're going to have is you're
going to have this
vocabulary right here it's also called a
code book let's call it a code book
so the codebook is also the vocabulary
so what you're saying is that um
you can't just output any or any
latent encoding so the the encoder
outputs a continuous vector
but what you're saying is it has to be
one of those
like there are a number of vectors that
you have at your disposal
uh mr or miss encoder or mrs encoder
there is a number of vectors that you
have at your disposal you can only
choose those
you can't choose any vector that you
want right
so in your latent space you can't just
choose any latent space there's this
there's this there's this there's this
there's this
you have to choose one of them and if
you choose
something in between which you'll
inevitably will because
this all of our neural networks output
continuous values
we're just going to clamp you we're just
going to find the nearest
one in our codebook and we'll just say
well we
we just make it such that you as if you
had output that one
so the encoder can only hit one of those
code book vectors
and then you feed these code book
vectors to the decoder
and the decoder just decodes from these
code book vectors
okay and that turns out to be much much
much better than simply doing the
autoencoder thing continuously
so imagine that this codebook vocabulary
is sort of like
a vocabulary of image descriptions
what you do with an image you take this
dog image i'm gonna have to draw this
myself
you take the image here of
the dog i can't draw dogs i'm very good
at cats though
um this is a cat and
you don't just encode this into one of
these words you
what you do is you split the image up
into a grid it's not as fine as
pixels it's fairly it's it's okay large
so
in their experiments they're going to
use something like 32 by 32
grids um which is also what dolly
uses every image is described by 1024
tokens that's 32 by 32 tokens
and then you're going to encode you're
going to
make an encoder such that when
this grid is through the encoder
this thing here corresponds to one of
the code vectors
and this thing here corresponds to
another one so you have your big
vocabulary
right here right
and this is the the red vector this is
the blue vector
this is the green vector and you're
going to just
describe the image regions with these
code book vectors
like such
okay now the fact that is you have you
have a lot of these vectors
right you have in in fact you have 8092
vectors
in dolly and the image only consists of
1024 um
tokens so you know it's conceivable like
it's not like here where you have to
reuse the same token over and over again
but one of these tokens could for
example be sky
so maybe this is the thing that sort of
describes sky
so what you you'll have is like this
thing and this thing and this thing and
this thing
should be approximately sky right and
then
maybe the red one is um
is i don't know animal and the blue one
is vegetation and the green one is
some something else so you can see if
you feed this to a model
that has to make a picture from it it
can just look at this
and it's sort of like a description a
low resolution description of an image
it's not exactly a down sampled image
it's a it's a description because these
things here contain
a lot of information by themselves
okay it's just that you can't choose
any vector in latent space you have to
choose one of those
vectors in the code book so that's a
vector quantized
vae and they train everything at the
same time so they train the encoder and
decoder
with this straight through estimator
because
this nearest neighbor computation isn't
exactly differentiable
they also train the code book to match
the outputs of the encoder so you can
train that
or you can just take the the exponential
average
of the encoder outputs and
that's the vq vae which is developed
more in
vq vae 2 so this is vq va2 i've linked
the papers
v q vae
what's i was writing a three two uh the
version two of it
does the same thing but in multi-scale
so here you can see
that in the encoder you
you you take the image and you put it at
multiple resolutions so this
is large resolution this is low
resolution
then you use the vector quantization to
encode this
into this grid and encode this into the
code book vectors so again here maybe
you have red
red red this is red and this is the
green one
and so on so you each square has to
choose one of these 8 000 vectors to
represent
itself and then you do this sort of
hierarchical thing
where you use the d a decoder
on this level to produce a slightly
higher resolution image
but then you quantize again and you use
a decoder at a next level to
produce an even higher resolution image
so you can see that
this hierarchical models usually these
hierarchical models if you want
good high resolution images you sort of
need them so you can see that
the the top decoder here outputs
something
quite blocky and then every
every additional one adds a
sort of details to the image it's pretty
impressive as
such and you can see the the training
right here um of the vqa these are these
are
papers from last year or the years
before so this
has been known what dali does
is from what i can gather from the blog
post
right here um
the images are pre-processed to 256 to
256 during training
similar to the qva each image is
compressed to a 32 by 32 grid of
discrete latent codes
using a discrete vae that we pre-trained
using a continuous relaxation okay there
there's
a lot of um there's a lot of
stuff here so um
the vae is pre-trained and they're
saying
they're saying also down here that their
model
uses maximum likelihood to to generate
all of the tokens
one after another it's decoder only and
so on
so probably this whole pipeline here is
pre-trained they pre-train
a vae a discrete vae
and then they simply the dolly model
simply has to learn how to produce the
tokens right the dolly model
simply has to learn how to produce these
hieroglyphs and the box
is fixed the box is not changed it's
possible that they also train
the decoder here so the decoder
but i don't know i can't tell this from
the blog post
what's certainly is that they what's
certain is that they
don't train the encoder
okay so what you would do in a single
step of dolly
is you would have your text right here
blah
blah blah and you would have a partial
image
okay you would input this text and the
partial image
to dully the partial
image is any image where you've blacked
out
the bottom right and they do the bottom
right
simply it's it's the same as if you do
left to right by text so you do
so sort of top left to bottom right and
yeah it's it's good because you can
always flip an image
maybe not actually but it's just a bias
that you have to
provide the model with in order to do
autoregressive
training right so here is the image of
that cat
right
[Music]
and you black out the bottom right you
can black out the whole image if you
want the model to produce
images unconditionally all right so you
block all of this
out cool
so now what you do is
these here they are already
they are already words right you
tokenize those token token token
and you go into your vocabulary of text
right so there's a vocabulary of text
somewhere there's blah
and you encode all of these using that
vocabulary so this is maybe word
34 so this is word 34
34 34.
you go to your image you
rasterize this according to your
definition okay and then you go
and run this through this encoder that
you trained
so you run it through the box and the
box
will tell you for each of this
grid outputs well the box will tell you
well in my in my vocabulary of
image pieces uh this here
is number two this here is number four
this is two again this is 35 and so on
so you do this left to right top to
bottom
and then you put it right here okay
so this is followed by an image of
2 4 2 35
and what you ask the model to do is
simply to predict from all of this
and the model knows that these are this
is text and this is images
from all of this predict the next token
which would be this token right here so
you want to predict
this one right here
what is it and that's how you train the
model right and once it gets that
you can train you can ask it to predict
the next one
and so on and in this way you can let it
generate an entire image at inference
time and
you know you can train this they say all
these tokens are generated
autoregressively
now in my understanding this is all the
model does because
once you have that token so if the model
says this is number seven
you go back to your box and you say
please or well it's a different box like
this is the encoder
this is the encoder of the vq vae
and now you go to your decoder that
you've also pre-trained right this is a
different box
and you ask it i have this image
right i have 2 4 2
35 and 7. uh please generate
an image for me for that or maybe you
want to we want to wait until you have
the
complete image right so you have the
complete image
and you give this to your decoder
and these are now that these hieroglyphs
right so you have the box and the box
produces
an image and the box says well okay
um this cat here probably
reproduces the ears fairly well because
you can describe them sort of exactly
maybe you also want to copy that over or
something
but then it says well it's a cut so i'm
going to
you know maybe this if
the model has done a good job there
should be
some sort of a cat right and the model
you know maybe in these hieroglyphs it's
even described how the cat looks like
the cat looks straight ahead
as whiskers as eyes and so on okay
so i'm going to guess that
the part on top that is trained
and the part on bottom is pre-trained
with the option that the decoder part
could also be trained
at training time at the same time they
train
this language model on top
so they make some further inferences
right here they say
um each image is compressed in
latent codes using a discrete ve that we
pre-trained using a continuous
relaxation
we found that training using the
relaxation obviates the need for an
explicit codebook
ema loss or tricks like dead code
revival and can scale up to large
vocabulary sizes
and this is the part where i i'm a bit
confused so clearly they say they have a
vocabulary
in the visual domain okay there are
eight thousand
one hundred and ninety two well i'm i'm
don't know my powers of two
eight thousand one hundred and ninety
two different
uh words in the code book so there must
be a code book
but they say there this obviates the
need for an explicit code book
so i don't really know what to make of
that
um i can tell you what a continuous
relaxation
might look like so this is from a
different paper that
that they linked of the concrete random
variables
so if you have an operation such as this
like a discrete random variable you need
to take an
arg max of it what you'll have
is you'll have some sort of logits right
that are maybe like this and
you take the arg max of it which means
that you
put it into a distribution where it's
just one
value and this is sort of the same
operation as we do in the vq vae
where we assign each um
each output of the encoder to the
nearest codebook vector we say you can
only have one of the codebook vectors
that's it right now what you want to do
when you relax this
is you want to say well instead of that
what you could do is you could just kind
of
take that code book vector a lot but
also you know
take a little bit of the others
so more than um doing a hard assignment
to a code book vector
right so here would be the output of
your encoder and you hard assign it to
the nearest neighbor
um you want to say
well i'm going to soft assign it to
all the ones it's sort of like the
difference between k nearest neighbor
and
a gaussian mixture model as i understand
not not what they do here
but it's analogous to that and
with that they don't need an explicit
code book and i don't know what that
means what i can imagine
is that they don't actually train the
codebook vectors
maybe they just
quantize to some prefixed schema or i
just don't understand
what they do yeah here is an
illustration of these discrete random
variables so you want to
get to a point when when you sample
the variable um as you drop your
temperature it more and more approaches
this
fixed sampling like you can be either
here or here or
here with the sort of masses that are
indicated by the size of the circle
but as you increase the temperature you
go more to a mixture so
yeah you can be at the corner but you
can also be kind of in this region or in
this region or in this region
as you increase the temperature you can
see the the
uh distribution becomes more of a
mixture
distribution and the mixture
distribution
any mixture distribution with a
temperature other than zero
of course now all of a sudden has sort
of a defined gradient
whereas these discrete random variables
they do not have a gradient
and that's the reason why the vq vae
needs to do this
straight through estimator right here
because this hard assignment to the code
book
does not have a gradient defined
with the soft relaxation you do have a
gradient
and maybe they just mean they don't need
um they don't need this hard assignment
to the code book
i'm not sure or maybe they they just
they quantize in a different way maybe
they go back to a continuous
latent space um
yeah i can imagine they they might go
back to a continuous latent space but
somehow somehow they uh still
do this a form of quantization
this could be a fixed quantization like
you say okay you can
choose any of the basis vectors and
some some mixtures that we define
between them or
they define it via moving averages or
they define it via batch statistics or i
don't know
if you know let me know in the comments
to the video
all right so this was my take on what
the model does
and what is probably behind it now let's
look at some more
examples right here because these are
fun
so they they say it can sort of control
attributes so you see these it's for
example a pentagonal green clock and you
see it's not always pentagonal it's
sometimes hexagonal and sometimes
heptagonal
and whatnot but in general what it does
well
is sort of color and also kind of object
description so
lunchbox it gets and green it gets what
it can't do super well is
stuff like counting um
so i have sort of a hypothesis i have
multiple hypotheses about here
just see watch in all of these examples
how the text prompt is phrased
so it says a pentagonal green launch box
a green
lunch box in the shape of a pentagon
this is quite unusual way to phrase
the the prompt and by the way all these
criticisms that
i'm leveraging here most of them are
actually admitted
and discussed in this blog post it's
actually it's pretty cool and pretty
self
let's say self critical of them so it's
this is um um i've you know i thought of
these things
and then i read the little text and then
they they already describe what i
concluded
it's sad but um yeah it's it's pretty
cool
of them because the current climate is
sort of uh make your research look as
as cool and flawless as possible
this goes a bit against it so
they say that the images here aren't
cherry picked
and i totally believe this so they have
a little
trick that they do they output i think
images from their model because they can
sample and then they re-rank
them using this other model that they've
released this clip
model and this clip model is a pretty
good re-ranker
um so you give it a piece of text and an
image and sort of tells you how well
they
fit together and it so the outputs that
you see here are re-ranked by this model
so what you see are strictly the best
outputs according to that model so it's
not cherry picked by humans but it's
cherry picked by a
very good model and the second thing is
that
the text prompt here is absolutely
cherry picked right
um by the way this is phrased
you can see that it is very very brittle
probably the model i can't test it but
probably it's very brittle in how
exactly
you phrase this text prompt and i'm
going to guess they have tried
a lot of things before they've released
these
few examples uh right here that
they show and they've you know made sure
that they work
so yeah just keep in mind
that this is very brittle and we already
know this from like gpt 3
we know that the input
might seem the same to a human just
phrased differently in some cases and
yet the model will output completely
different things and we know that
a lot of these gpt3 examples are very
very
constructed in terms of the input prompt
so yeah the other thing is the model as
i said it can
do colors and it can do colors and and
textures pretty well so we've already
seen
um the things made of things
so the sphere made of noodles that
actually probably exist the sphere made
of guacamole
um however it's not super good at
counting for example and i have a
sort of multiple hypotheses so these
image models they tend to be very good
at
sort of style and texture style and
texture are
the domain of these image models like
anywhere where there's like
a convolution and by the way they use
in the vq vae model uh no not in the vq
vae
in this transformer for images they
don't do full attention
what they do is each one of the image
tokens can
attend to each of the text tokens such
as this
but the image tokens they can only sort
of attend
um in the grid
layer by layer at in one layer they can
attend sort of
to the row of other image
elements in another layer they can
attend to the same column
and in even another layer they can
attend to sort of the
the surroundings of them like a
convolution so they can attend to
let's say their couple of neighbors
right here
uh so it's not full attention yet in
every layer
every image token can attend to all the
text tokens
okay so um
yeah in these models what you'll
typically see is that
textures and style is pretty good
however
global correspondences are not as good
and that's what you see a lot in these
face models um where the left and the
right earring
don't match and things like this so
global correspondences are not so good
and you would actually expect that
objects aren't
as good as well right so here this is
still a clock this is still a light bulb
this is still a stop sign right so it
somehow gets the objects correct which
in my hypothesis it shouldn't
because um this is some sort of a global
structure however
i think that's just a matter of how the
data set is collected the data sets are
probably
we humans we take pictures of objects
right so so the the fundamental
structures in these data sets
is the object so it makes sense that it
learns that
we humans we don't we don't take
pictures and we often don't describe
the count in them so i can get that the
model has a harder time to learn that
and actually focuses just on the
object as a global thing the count would
be a global thing right but
it's not that prominent in the data and
the rest is
a local thing like the color the texture
and so on yeah the cube made of
porcupine
so you can see here that um this this
counting
so two is often quite good actually here
it mixes up glasses and
glasses right um so two often works
however if you go if you go past two
um it often gets it wrong so
five you'll get anything from three to
seven
uh clocks and so on so
i'm going to also guess it's very
brittle like they're not
here yes they're sitting on a table but
if you take
a object that's not that often on a
table
like a club you'll see that it's pretty
unrecognizable whether or not it's on a
table
um five four clubs
so you know the model is prone to
ignoring part of its input if the
likelihood in another part
is larger
also it can't do things like this
you know a stack of three cubes a red
cube is on the top sitting on a green
cube
it often gets the order wrong like it
gets yeah the cubes on top of each other
however it often gets it wrong when it
comes to you know the order the global
things as i said anything global that is
not
what the object is uh tends to be weak
anything local tends to be strong in
these models and that's
just a matter of how they're built and
how the data is
so they say uh the image can render
new views and here is where i'm not as
convinced so here you have like an
extreme close-up view of a cobby
cup cabby bar sorry um
of a fox they're close up
sometimes they're extreme close up right
um
you can see that it gets like forest it
gets it gets pretty well
but then you say okay ground level view
like
and then you say okay an aerial view
maybe some of them are aerial views some
of them aren't
um what's pretty cool is
things like a okay a fish eye lens view
i mean that's that's pretty cool
and a they have something
a bottom view or a rear view yeah the
rear view
works better so it does understand these
these
kind of things like what's the rear of a
fox and what's the front of a fox
though as you can also see not always
um texture it's very good at texture
so here something made of voxels can do
that
perfectly uh an owl
made of voxels like this looks like it
comes straight from minecraft right
absolutely absolutely cool even x-ray
sometimes doesn't always get the bones
right but
yeah as i said style structure
um very cool so here is an example of a
completion so they give the
the text prompt a photograph of a bust
of a homer
and the image the top part of the image
and they say
well it can describing a well-known
figure
it can complete the figure um i don't
agree
that it completes homer like it
completes it probably just
sees this bust and this
and it just completes you know whatever
fits
i i don't i have not studied homer
as a historic person or busts of him but
you know um
i i disagree that this depicts largely
the same person
very often you can see here um
there is sometimes there is even you
know there's completely
unrelated stuff there is that lady with
the pearl earring
by vermeer somewhere in there and so on
and what i also like in this kind of
this this one
you know the game draw something where
or you know pictionary and so on
there are people when they can't draw
something they just kind of write it
on the picture it's like ah screw it and
i'll just write it's like
this is homer this is homer no i don't
care what you say
this is homer but you know
it does you know it does um so when you
say cleopatra
it it goes uh more into the
into sort of the uh female direction
medusa uh it has you know some
though i'm pretty sure medusa has the
the snake
the snake hair no maybe
venus yeah
somewhat somewhat um
it they test a lot of things like can it
do
mirror reflections and you can see right
here they say it can do reflections on
the ground
pretty well but it can't do reflections
for example in a mirror because in a lot
of these pictures
the object like here would actually have
to be in front of the mirror however
in the fewest amount of pictures
the object mirrored is actually also in
front of the mirror so this kind of
global correspondence
isn't given as much however there is a
fair bit of reflection
on the ground so to say so you know
that's pretty cool but it's also
probably very very common
in data sets um yeah cross-section
view of a walnut so they sort of implore
sorry explore the model what it can do
and here you can see that you know if
something is common in the data set you
know like the
the cross section of human head there
are a lot of pictures of that
right in the data set however if it
comes to cross-section view
of a where where did i see the
airplane there is an airplane somewhere
it's
less it's less so so
um you can see that this is still it is
so
here it probably doesn't really know how
that looks because
you know they probably on the image on
the internet even on the whole
internet pictures of cross sections of
airplanes or any sections of airplanes
are
not really distributed often so it
sort of just focuses on airplane and
then with cross-section it probably
knows that it should somehow display
some of the interior so it just kind of
produces some stuff that matches this
thing
as i said if if it can't make the
likelihood
high of all of the things
what it tends to do is just focus on one
of the things and just make that
likelihood
high which is reasonable you know for a
model
um a macro photo macro photographs of
stuff
these are pretty cool this is what you
would find in some
image galleries absolutely
uh then it can do various things like
style transfer and here is where it
shines right
a so you can have different paintings
of different objects in different styles
so
here you can like have an owl sitting in
the forest
um in the morning
and you can have this as a painting as a
painting in the pop art style and so on
it's very very impressive so i
absolutely am blurry actually too like
as a postage stamp
um these are these are these are
absolutely
amazing and yeah you can have stuff like
stained glass windows and this is yeah
it's where the model shines and even
here a storefront that has the word
opener written on it so
just right now just look at how
convoluted this text prompt has to be
for them to get this to work
it's impressive but the text prompt
has to be repeated and reformulated a
bunch of times and so on
my personal favorite is the
pie torch chips um they're crunchy
uh you get a piece of back prop in every
package
and so you can see it sometimes misses
like this is perch
perch chips and so on uh it sometimes
misses
but it is pretty cool that it basically
can do ocr
right or reverse ocr uh
you can you give it a a piece of text
and it sort of makes a picture
with that on it it's very very
impressive even though as we said like
the global the global correspondences
are not always there um
they do implore like fashion a skirt
like here the yellow skirt um
then you know these mannequins
and here they have a love bedroom with a
white bed
next to a nightstand there is a fish
tank standing beside the bed and they
give sort of the beginning of the image
and here's what the model comes up with
and you know you can imagine that there
are a lot of pictures like this in the
data set
so the model might be pretty good at
stuff like this
though i have found their king bed
next to yeah let's say the nightstand
with the telescope the telescope
beside the bed he just you know that
beside like there's a telescope
sometimes it's on the bed
sometimes it's next to it there's some
weird telescopes around
well this is a lot of telescopes
that's a weird telescope but you know
the
quality is pretty impressive this is
absolutely nitpicking
that i'm doing here combining unrelated
concepts we've already seen the
armchair in the shape of an avocado they
also have a snail
made of harp though my personal favorite
is the penguin made of garlic
the penguin made of garlic
this perfect right
absolutely adorable and
just qualitatively like this this
would take a human like you would pay a
high quality
um highly educated photoshop artist
quite a bit of money to get this sort of
output
right and these models they they shine
at this sort of style transfer
texture stuff and it was here yeah you
have the illustrations
you can have any kind of illustrations
like the illustration
of a baby shark with
a mustache um
holding there's holding an umbrella
somewhere
playing it running riding a unicycle
it's just it's just nice and
as i said this is the same model that
can do all of this stuff
and these are samples they're just
samples they're not cherry picked
however they are re-ranked
remember that um so
they can do you know hybrids of images
hybrids of different
um giraffe and turtle and so on
and they do sort of implore the model
a little bit more where they as i said
they give this cat on the top and they
say they want
the exact same cat on the top as
a photo colored blue on the bottom so
you can see that
it doesn't always work right
but in a surprising amount of times
it actually does work sometimes it's
just like a blue pot
but you can you can see
it's not the finished model yet
however it is a step into the direction
that shows us that this is definitely
definitely possible it can even do some
of these progressive matrices where it
fills in the bottom right
however they do mention it's very very
finicky
with respect to whether or not for
example if you invert the color so if
you look at the bottom
right of any of these things if i invert
the colors
uh the output sort of changes and
it's often also not right um
however sometimes it is actually right
which is
crazy because in some of these things
you have to do
some crazy sort of inference that
um we usually we usually do these things
in iq tests
so i don't know the debate about what is
intelligence
goes on they say it has geographic
knowledge
however i'm not sure it has geographic
knowledge as it just associates
words with particular images like they
say okay this is a photo of
food of china um okay
maybe you just i'm not sure this
classifies as geographic knowledge
is yeah also this temporal knowledge a
photo
of a phone from the 20s okay
you know and then the different time
periods 60s 70s 80s
future and so on like distant future
like
wow these phones um i particularly
so i like the usually this stuff
it's it's pretty okay right but it's not
temporal knowledge
it just associates a bunch of tokens
with some sort of style of computer
today's computer the future computer the
distant future computer
please no please don't please please
don't give me that
i don't want to i don't want that i love
the action movie poster
because so the style is correct
but you know it just says action movie
in the future yeah
they do get sort of the kind of some of
the styles of
it just it just says action movie like
this is like a
like a naggy laggy child like um
i'm hungry hi hungry i'm dead
all right so they also have a summary
right here
and they do show what it means that they
they use this clip to re-rank so on the
left here
you can see just eight samples straight
up from the model
and they're not too bad but you know you
increase
the quality by sort of sampling more and
then taking the best eight
as you go to the right here um according
to
the re-ranker so i'm gonna guess they
decided on 512 because that was
sort of you know it gives you already
pretty
diverse pretty good pretty high quality
outputs right here
all right so just uh lastly shout out to
the
the the offers right here uh the primary
authors are the terra mesh
mikhail pavlov gabriel go and scott
ray with a i guess
the secondary supporting authors and
most
open ai behind them though i don't know
how they work
i would encourage you to go look at the
model
it's pretty cool uh try out all these
inputs as i said these are
the inputs are simply restricting you
uh because they don't trust you with
their model yet
right in the real model you can input
any piece of text
that you want um and you will get out an
image
and the fact that you have to select
this stuff here is simply because
that's the stuff they tried that's the
stuff their pr department has
signed off on right and um
uh so so you get to see that because
as i said that they they're not like
this is at the same time this is a pr uh
dilemma when you release a generative
model because it
you know it could release and they
discussed this a little bit in the blog
post you know it could release
like it's very problem problematic
images in a classifier it's not as
pronounced it's also
sometimes dangerous but not as dangerous
as
if you have a generative model that's
the first thing and the second thing is
there is
i mean there is money in this um
definitely
definitely money to be made
in this so you know we'll see whether or
not we get
the full model or not all right with
that that was it from me
i hope you enjoy the blog post i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did let me know share it out
subscribe if you haven't
and bye bye